people who play video games have much
better computational skills much better
logic skills
hi I'm Tracy Oppenheimer for reason TV
and we're here at the 2013 global
conference i'm talking with nolan
bushnell he is often cited as the father
video games CEO of brain rush and author
of the recent book finding the next
Steve Jobs Nolan thanks so much for
talking with us my pleasure as the
father of video games you started with
Atari over four decades ago it's been a
long path since then sometimes that
they're criticized heavily but you're
saying this kind of technology can
actually be used in a positive way our
brains are really the product of what we
do and what people are not telling you
though they should is that kids IQs
today or higher than they were before
people who play video games have much
better computational skills much better
logic skills much better you know
surgeon and and cognitive skills and
kids who don't we believe that we can
use some of the things that we
discovered in designing video games to
put meaningful content teach kids very
quickly have it be fun to learn because
one of the problems with school today is
it's boring to the kids who are used to
these rapid action very very diverse
kinds of thinking that you get in any of
the video games even movies and fast
cuts and and multitasking they don't get
that in school and therefore it seems
like the information is coming really
slow and that's a problem and so what we
really want to do is maintain above all
passion and enthusiasm because with
passion and enthusiasm people can be
lifelong learners they can be engaged in
life they can be happy you know there's
all kinds of wonderful things that
happen when we don't destroy that
passion and too many of our schools
today destroy that passion one of your
other points is that one-on-one learning
is really important in the way our
public education
system was set up that that's not very
probable so and you want to bring
computers into that but how can helping
computers personalized education well
what what you really want to do is you
want to unburden the teacher teaching is
a horribly difficult job if a teacher is
a tremendous educator a tremendous
mentor but can't maintain classroom
discipline can't maintain the
entertainment to keep all the kids
laughing and giggling then they're
perceived to be a bad teacher when in
fact there may be the best at teaching
so what we want to do is we want to take
a lot of the drudgery and put the kids
on the computer so if you say the
typical classroom with 35 and if you
have 30 of them working on projects and
or computers the teacher can focus on
five on a very very personal basis so
you foresee a very huge transformation
in education over the next few years it
turns out that our software we have
building these tools that will allow any
teacher to create curriculum that is 10
times more effective and so think of
every kid learning at 10 times the speed
and they say well what Gray's I said all
the grades our software works in pre-k
to post gray and so this is whether
you're studying nursing or automobile
mechanics or jet engine repair or
algebra or geometry or American
Constitution all of this stuff can be
fit into one of our angels and what
those do is that uses brain science to
present things in a kind of gamified way
and it's really fast and when kids are
learning quickly they think it's fun
even if it's kind of a boring subject
Nolan thank you so much again for
talking to us I had fun that's nice
meeting you all friesen TV I'm Tracy
Oppenheimer
you